james johnson the four court troubles to
kevin durant three-point gunning it goes
kd with
killian hayes
not getting close enough
sadiq shovels to frank jackson for a
long gun it won't go
[Applause]
durant to four four pull up line drive
gun goes
this is with 19 seconds and plenty of
time on that shot clock
and the nets knock it away
durant to griffin
to kd for the shot sticks it
three assists in ten minutes
it's kind of like his productivity in
the g league yeah
this is the free throw with hamadou
durant on the other end fires and fills
it up
against isiah stewart off the dribble
fires no
aldridge shovels it to james johnson top
side of durant
by himself and he buries it not a guy to
give a second chance
immediately anyway
kevin durant against sadiq bay
kd to the basket hooks and hits
was determined to get a shot
and he got one
but he's ready he's ready tonight when
called on and he's playing extremely
well
durant fires and fills it
for the nets
i like that giving it up to a cutting
isaiah stewart
kevin durant ducks in scoops and scores
what a move
good night sticking his nose in there he
wasn't backing down the clock on that
end of the court he has no fear durant
with the turnip gun though and it goes
[Music]
kevin durant
the basket lays it up plays it in
showing you the other part of his game
the hamadou
puts it up wide
rebound bembry
membry way ahead to durant for a dog you
know what's really horrible about that
no call
first of all it was a foul
you can shoot the basketball
has a duran can two he fires he fills it
a triple for duran
and the pistons are up six
durant thrills it from behind the long
line it's impressive
first minute fourth quarter three loud
cut inside lost the ball claxton knocked
it away yeah quick answer and good
anticipation there by claxton he's ready
durant
triples over trey lyles
durant one point shy of 50.
durant to the baseline and now he has 51
and that's a new arena record